I just saw a great comet in chat to
bring us live a niche that I'm gonna
have an expensive Father's Day if I
don't get my stuff together I've already
got I've already got two two on this
list and you know I don't know though I
just don't when I look at you I see the
facial hair but you seems too young to
be a dad I got well I tried I tried
today all I could I mean I have some
kind of grandpa hoody I'm do the shave
for like one 1/2 day so it's funny
trying I'm trying I've been rocking the
unshaven I shaved today just so I could
have that baby face that you would want
if you were bringing a new member of
your family so there will be plenty of
jokes ahead but let's remind everybody
who's here what they're in for this is
the adopted Danny show where once a
month I try to defend my life against a
super grand master defend my honor if
you will or not so far I have failed to
do so successfully through all three
time controls or the other way to look
at it Aneesh is I has I have
successfully avoided adoption at least
one time in every show that's the other
way to look at it yeah well you can
always take something positive out okay
I mean so put your tell them before we
talk a little bit about some of the
stuff we're doing here we'll remind you
the format and the charity no people
your chances here I got a I got a lot
I'm not gonna lie you don't seem super
confident against me that's the yeah
basically hurtful my predecessors my co
whatever co-parents or whatever you call
them
Maximus Telegraph and Wesley so are just
tremendous blitz specialists so it's not
a given that I am you know I'm going to
rise up to the expectations they left
everybody with and also as you see know
from our combined commentary and all the
other things we did I have tremendous
respect for you I mean I it was me who
invented the term super international
master for you so I it's going to be
hard for me to to get over that I'm I
have tremendous respect for you and I
think whenever you'll get a good
position I'm gonna be extremely nervous
and slow so but let's see yes yeah I've
been playing chess for a while sometimes
sometimes I manage so let's see you're
not so bad at it right and you have you
some some viral viral moments recently
you've had you had a great event at the
Magnus Invitational how's the online
chess world been going for you this
whole transition during koban 19 are you
do you feel like you're playing better
chest right now online then you were at
the start of this pandemic just like
curious well I'm definitely more in the
mood for it I don't have the quality of
my chest has improved yet but I'm sort
of more I feel like it's easier for me
it goes a bit easier and in particular
the phase of the time trouble is much
better when I have a few seconds left I
think I've improved that already but I I
mean I'm not yet I mean I'm watching
sometimes the likes of Hikaru and rush
Telegraph and an opponent she of course
crosses these icons of online chess I
mean they they play so well I remember
where to go but I'm I'm trying I really
enjoy it I enjoy playing online yeah
it's it's been an interesting thing and
like you said there's the icons of
online chess that are playing a lot
regardless of what's going on with no
over the board chess but I mean from the
outside looking at it seems to me like
you're playing better so that's not me
just trying to butter up my new dad
maybe I'm just letting you know it seems
that way but let me um let me take a
second to remind everybody of what we're
doing here so again this is the adopted
DNA show a nice giri will be playing me
in three different time controls three
different blitz bullet disciplines we're
gonna do five oh we're gonna do three oh
and then we're gonna do bullet if he
wins ten games in a row that's
considered an adoption a term that
became very popular here in online chess
over the last couple years and as the as
the pop culture around who's adopted who
over the years grew Hikaru seems to have
adopted everybody but anyway regardless
of that I think it gave us a chance to
maybe have some fun with the show like
this that we do once a month and we also
raise money for a charity let's remind
everybody of what the Dave Thomas
foundation for adoption is all about you
can go to Dave Thomas foundation org
it's it's really the all in one if you
have any interest in in supporting
lending any kind of help toward not only
kids looking for a for a home but also
the process that the circles that the
the transition to too
coming comfortable in a new family they
work and provide therapists and and help
and support and all kinds of different
social work that that really helps the
adoption process so Anish that's that's
another reason we're doing this and I
have to ask you your your I mean what
will take a serious note you're a dad
right and you have an amazing kid with
an amazing first name I mean can we just
appreciate yes your kid's name I've got
a Denny
I've got a Daniel it idea could you even
could you and so poco handle to Danny's
to Daniel's I mean well I mean it would
not be it's not the most ordinary things
parents don't like to get to children
with the same name but very special
occasion I think we'll well I mean let
me ask you I mean who as we as we take
it out here and again we appreciate in
advance everyone who is consistently
shown support as we try to raise money
for charity while we do the show have
you guys ever considered I mean I don't
know I mean not to get too personal do
you guys consider having more children
and would you ever consider adoption of
you and so poco ever talk about
something like that no we didn't discuss
the adoption but it's definitely
definitely a great thing because I mean
families deserve to have children and
children deserve to have family so in
that sense I think it's it's a great
thing for for so many families and so
many children out there so it's yeah
it's it's really also I'm always happy
to to do an event like that that
contributes to the real worlds as well
because of course it's fun to to play
chess and between us chess players we
have a lot of fun and chess fans enjoy
it too but it's also nice when you can
make a difference in some people's life
and I'm really happy that you guys are
doing this project I appreciate that and
so we'll see what we were able to today
we've raised raised and hit our goal
every show we hope to do it again today
so thank you everyone is here and
whatever support you you do a want or
decide to give the the chest is about to
go down I'm checking out the team here
looks like we're gonna go down so
reminder that yeah I'll send you a
challenge your Anish and you'll see it
come in here in just a second reminder
that Aneesh and I will only be playing
we will not
you know be observing or following chats
so there's no clues or worries about
that we will not see any evaluation of
position whatever we're just going to
play and have fun and we are not too
long away so I'm gonna go find that a
nice Giri
Wow he's right at the top of the rating
list I'm nervous everybody nice guy
everybody left all the hydrated players
left oh yah yah is there
yawns there so you're there all right so
we're gonna challenge you we're starting
out with 5-minute and the color will be
random and as soon as I click play we're
gonna we're gonna start actually wait it
says in each Giri is not accepting
challenges that's what I was suspecting
that's what I was suspecting yeah yeah
no usually I gotta force into I have the
power of four to play he was really bad
it sounds really bad again let's let's
force let's force it oh there we go okay
we go you change your settings and we're
good here we go we're rockin II for the
clock started ticking so I just made a
move so first thing before I before I do
anything different I have to I have to
go to the Sicilian and see what you're
all about yeah this is the trial just
checking out you know each other
theories theoretical knowledge my dad my
dad plays the night over to my other dad
so I'm gonna I'm gonna go get lucky
lying here and see what you remember
yeah no of course
should have known you've got some tricks
up their sleeve I don't remember this
stuff it's for my whole repertoire is
dubious tricks man oh this this is
losing by force I think but it is this
whole line loses by force I don't
remember how though yeah okay does not
even me what am I supposed to do here
this is
this is so much - that hamster
courti i remember somewhere it was this
awkward weird move c3 but I don't know
if it's here
[Music]
you really do that
doesn't make any sense to me but okay
any sense anymore
oh the only fun thing I know of this
position is at some point you have moves
like this and everyone's happy
my happy I'm happy everyone's happy it's
clear to me that
are you sure about this it's clear to me
that in general my plan for this match
is going to be
just flagging you later on there were
there's always a gamer to where I'm just
like winning and up a rook or something
and and then I get flagged so don't
worry you'll you'll join the club on
that yeah but it's not really happening
you seem to know your stuff yeah all
right because it seems like it should be
losing what maybe it doesn't I don't
know everything about this line feels
losing but it's not actually I actually
lost a game on the white side of this to
Wesley so in our last adopted Danny show
oh wow I don't know
I was trying some aged five four
Giselle but I didn't see how it mates
I'm just going to simplify yeah I don't
know either I mean I'm not just like
saying that like I lose you have no idea
what's going on right now I think
everybody believes you yeah
you
okay
now we get spicy
it's okay this is first game is
unimportant because like it's very bad
to break a streak but I don't have a
streak so it has there's no pressure on
me no pressure on it's true it's true
okay how do I do this how do I do this
take your time a couple minutes I've
tried trying to think right now
you
it looks better for you than we thought
right
you
I don't even have a good way to give you
all my material that's usually my go-to
Jam and just give up all your pieces I
don't even have an easy way to do that
we're gonna sometimes play some kind of
fun look at that uh-uh no no no no no no
go on you're proud of that move and you
do it no no no I'm not I'm not
the simplest the simplest move is the
best move or Nathan when you use good
grandmaster logic
yeah this is quickly quickly become a
less than ideal
in Bishop g7 was good to take some queen
III check intermediate move was very
strong which I originally missed you
protect h6 yeah again intermediate move
I'm trying to I'm trying to tilt you now
by telling you all the things you missed
yeah that's actually I mean it doesn't
tell me because I'm used to that I'm
used to missing things but I do
appreciate the effort of building me
hold on I'm gonna try to think do I have
some sort of weird opportunity for
tricks here that's all I got let me
think
all right we're gonna go for this and
did other players talk to you during
that game so what was the how did they
behave yeah
Maxime was a little more like kind of an
abusive dad right off for the start
right off the bat uh-huh
Wesley Wesley's a little more subtle but
he's got some you know there's a little
more bite - Wesley as we know you know
you know let's definitely have some
zingers in there
Wesley's only looks like a nice guy yeah
he had a very brutal game where he like
blundered a rook against me out of the
opening and then just went like full
flag mode and I just got flagged and it
was it hurts so bad
nobody knows what you're doing right now
there's some kind of course um I know
I'm you know I'm not so sure that I
didn't have
a little better than I came up with so
we'll see
you
yeah this is starting to get ugly right
avenge
this move is just trying to prevent dot
yeah I'm just trying to prevent you from
putting the Brooke on e1 and then
winning e5 and okay didn't succeed nope
I just made you're not winning e5 right
away is it okay if I weenie four or this
that's true um that wasn't part of my
plan
hmm okay I'm I'm going to let you have a
5 or a 4 or whatever point you want you
can say what you're so sweet yeah oh
wait let's just take this one
yeah that didn't go well either right
that's not happening in a good sense for
me
I'm not even speaking sense right now
no because we just had a discussion with
my friend before the show about the
value of pieces and how relevant it is
yeah the fact that truck is supposedly
Fife and the bishop is supposedly three
is somewhat relevant when it comes to
the Bishop of 637 configuration yeah
this is a problem
okay well this is normally how the first
game goes it's okay and then we just
take a breath here but now the pressure
pressure is on me now because I have
some sort of a streak potential now I'm
nervous yeah now you should be nervous
right now we now we go again here we go
now I'm white and first thing I have to
do I always have to play e4 and see
where that's gonna go we just play
exactly the same game with colors
reversed right I mean if you're into
that I'm not though tricked you know
this is not fair how many this just go
through it through
now you're going for the authentic here
they're ill after real Englishmen the
real Englishmen that's my that's my
thing
that maybe you want to put a knight on
f3 but you are no no I got more
additional looking Nobles do I look like
a positional guy I stopped your differ
okay so when did you break 3,000 like
when did that happen
I don't actually know but I've been I
think it might have happened in one of
the official events like the speech
Hampshire something because but ya know
at some point I also purposefully try to
because
there is like a list in which you
in which you see the countryman yeah
like I wanted to become like at least to
become like best Dutchman that's what
people normally associate me with and it
turned to prove to be even harder than I
thought so I yeah there's some point in
that race maybe I've got over 2,000 yeah
okay so
you
yeah I guess I'm just impressed and this
is not me you know I'm not trying to
talk smack subtly I'm just saying I
didn't know you were three I didn't know
you were in the 3000 Club
oh you want your I think you're fishing
for like some 2,500 compliment there
aren't you like I didn't know you are oh
I wish I wish I really was that would
have been that would have made me feel
smarter but I wasn't you are 25 you are
2,500 no no Mon it's on chess is calm
whole thing I mean I'm I'm barely above
2,500 every once in a while I tell
myself I'm gonna commit 2,600 but
usually it's on my phone with a glass of
wine so I start playing blitz and I win
the first couple games and as the night
goes on doesn't go well so usually if
people see me playing online at night
it's at home on my couch on my phone
with a glass of wine this is like this
is the reality is that how you encourage
has of calm users to behave
this is just realized chest drunk
history chess history drunk history
cattle dilation there we just got our
first $10 donation for the foundation
eesh great great I would have been much
happier about it had I had a good
position as well but nonetheless I'm
very happy
[Music]
yeah you you played quite well this 12 x
f4 move
I do know this line but now here comes
the tricky stuff how do I continue to
play this position as always the
question I think you don't know this
because usually what you should know is
what to do in case black plays well and
I play it very badly here so I think you
are out of book here yes
you know you're right me gradually I
should gradually switch to flagging like
gradually you know you're gradually not
that's because my position is
deteriorating but gradually so many good
things your I can even take and Bishop
e6 and 95 I mean that's a bind sometimes
I can this is one of those lines where
we both know that I'm gonna be better
and I'm gonna lose this game so let's
just say it
alright here we go I gotta focus come on
Dan come on Dan convert convert
something for once in your life
it's earlier to speak of conversion now
a little bit
for this line
that's like a queen how are you with
Queens do you like Queens um Queens are
not my favorite maegyr pieces are so you
can go for it no not falling for it
yepper dude
and too weak to slow
I know one minute behind on the clock
you
by the way I felt that this experience
before on one of the shows I don't know
on on chesil come show or elsewhere but
I
like I hear voices you know as they say
I hear voices now you're like some kind
of I hear some keyboard yeah maybe it's
because maybe the like to be switch I
think he can hear your keyboard my
producers in the background working hard
yeah yeah is that possible to said I
don't hear in his keyboard we'll switch
you guys when I work here is when I have
a bad position
things like keyboards they start to
annoy me so badly I mean I'm really I'm
ready to kill someone with that keyboard
I'm joking I don't have these ratio
things but yeah it's so nice well we
switched you for you yeah thank you
thank you thank you now I have no more
excuses now you're no more excuses now
you're just in a bad position and that's
okay with me hey what are you doing
they're just moving back and forth don't
get sneaky on my night over there back
and forth back and forth purposelessly
okay
you
well you defended for now
oh I knew you were gonna do this without
thinking just trying to impress
my only chance
using my super grandmaster
grandmaster instincts
the reputation combined with the
sacrifice tries trying to demoralize you
[Laughter]
this is where it gets spicy
you
all you want is a pond for all that
yeah better all with the punches as they
say
I think you are not you're not really
aware of my strategy at the moment I
hope you will become aware of it like a
couple of minutes later into the game
well I I suddenly realized that I don't
need to continue to fight for moving my
advantage more than just maybe maybe
speed up a little bit here
I know what you're doing let's just say
it's not the first time I've been
flagged okay
damnit she are on to me everyone about
this super Iams got a little bit I'm
Mike am I'm like a walking version of a
Toby Keith song you know I'm not as good
as I once was but every once in a while
you're getting confident there aren't
you whoa whoa great game as well
wonderful play I should start praising
you like the last unit they can't raise
them raise well yeah I know
nobody does it's like the ultimate dirty
trick
praising the guy
if you don't swindle me can you make
that happen for me
really trying very hard okay you are
asking for stuff but I guess doesn't
know
you are asking for a while
you
that was such a good move by me
what no
wait what are you doing you don't have
anything here
what you do no time how did I do this
own time don't worry gosh okay hold on
that still flag you that was tilted that
was stupid
that was not even fair
but I have been playing bullets yeah I'm
I can agree the other master yeah
okay you didn't do it
this is where it gets spicy
don't move it was there's an insanely
filthy trick not insane if you think way
break I didn't saw this coming I should
have just played Kings yeah you could
have gone no but actually it's not so
bad because I would pick up the rook the
Queen and the bishop it would be a
rockin game which I was holding even
let's back up and just show that that
little tactic dr. Denise just did if we
can we'll back up a few more moves so
right here you did
queen g4 vision of six so you're saying
instead of me taking your bishop on f6
okay no of course you shouldn't but
after you taking is also okay but after
taking check if you move the King I will
pick up the rook the Queen Bishop yeah
so I am getting back almost I mean all
of the materials are very good chances
there to hold the game but of course you
probably a draw although with with time
who knows okay but instead of taking us
six I could easily look actually it's
already kind of tricky then it's not so
easy I sure I mean taking on f6 is
practically fine otherwise it's not so
easy to make a move as long as I predict
from the mate you've got to watch out as
well for some tricks yeah yeah I was
feeling so good too
I should you know what I should have
done like the whole time I should just
forgotten h4 I kept telling myself just
like move the bishop and go like go like
offer a queen trade or something like
Queen c5 yeah exactly exactly yeah
Michael isn't the little the little the
little engine that could in me
there was a little engine that could
inside of me and it was like just just
keep chugging Dan just go Trey Queens
but I couldn't we had some donations we
had Jay s toca with a 10-buck dono we
had mr. Gucci with three bucks
efore e6 made 10 bucks thank you so much
guys for donating but I think Denia
after after your deal cornered this I
think they want their money back now I
don't know that anybody ever comes on
these shows to donate for me to impress
that's not why they're here they're not
here to donate for this for the quality
just for me anyway but alright here we
go I'm gonna send you a rematch now I'm
getting toasty now I'm getting warm your
mix it yeah it's right you're free that
night or varchar you don't want none of
that
yeah I just want to see I wanna see
what's your what you got okay I'll just
go with something real simple for you So
Solid
you are like some Hikaru Nakamura yeah
you only current a camera boy of course
aren't you yeah I'm just gonna place you
got here you've got your heroes
okay
well then if you're gonna play that game
you know got some fuel see I was gonna
steal the trick Xia
not the stuff they don't teach this
stuff in elite schools you know teach
this bathroom for anything at elite
schools of channel they don't teach this
this rubbish
unfortunately I'm not liking it actually
it's quite quite unpleasant to face
I think I think your position is great
must be must be
I want to go queen bee three but I'm
terrified so I'm gonna do that anyway
hmm
trying to punish with maybe it's a bad
thing to do let's see let's see what you
got
trying to punish me
historically can be very risky like
I tend to get away with a lot of
sneakiness stuff
a pro tip for the future don't want to
do that I don't want to do what you want
me to do
I'm not sure we're on the same page here
[Laughter]
that is funny
yeah we're probably not on the same page
so did you think did you think I wanted
you to do that or what was that I worry
I think you want you wanted me to take a
free uh-huh I didn't want anything to be
honest all right no yeah I just made a
move and I was just hoping it's a good
move and I didn't know what I want
that's how I usually play
I don't know go back
I'll just go back I regret my life
choices
it's a little bit right there I'm
baiting you right now
I'm not not going to do anything stupid
responsible parent here
ah
you
I forgot what were your scores overall
with the maxim and Wesley like without
counting adoptions like what is the
overall score obviously remembered I
don't remember right I don't even know
that's
that is a wild
question
I'm just gonna fight my instincts and
just play solid moves my instincts are
to play not solid moves
yeah that's bad instincts what can I say
now I feel like I need to
you
I know you're thinking I just pushed
your night where you want it to go I
know that I I didn't say that not to
insult you I wanted to looking so just
say it I was thinking exactly that
please you'll appear cocky shouldn't do
this you know just let him be a very
good gentlemen
that's what I was thinking which is that
I also wanted your might to have a
better square I was looking out for that
night ya know it's it's some kind of
animal should do some start some anymore
as well yeah yeah we are animal rights
activist here just calm ever since Tiger
King came out we've been thinking a lot
more about the safety of our nights yes
I heard about that show yeah
no why did I even do that I'm just
hoping you're not gonna like sacrifice
and make me here you know this thing's
this okay you are really
you're just voicing my thoughts I don't
even have to speak anymore on this show
because you're just telling everything
I'm thinking
why can't I do that by the way is there
something forbidding me to
like why can't I do this for example
you
I don't know why
what am i doing
you
what am i doing I'm not even like
thinking of the next move this is always
what happened I don't even like get my
critical thinking cap on I sound like
such a dad you know I'll let you have
your wrap on kids just just have your
hair have your rent here yeah yeah no I
I mean jokes aside that point moment
when you play it I mean Bishop e5 it was
like the way I play that was like half a
tempo behind to do what I want to do and
you gave me that half a tempo with
before because yeah if you had gone
Bishop Bishop f6 there yeah just with
the Bishop f6 I'm not able to
consolidate the d4 square so I think
yeah because if you take character play
92 then be twofold yeah exactly able to
do that
yeah b4 was just dumb classic okay well
I'm gonna huge trouble here let's finish
it out for the kids as dads together
let's finish this one out right let's
show everybody what's happening here
nice this is the problem and so many
fancy ways to lose this game
so let's see
go this way
yo all right there we go okay so okay
enjoy that check my keyboard
GGO it's not gonna happen that often
yeah
I shadow we have some more donations
greetings from the Netherlands so we've
got a supporter here I'm a nice giri
Harold with the ten to ten bucks and
then we have Swiss Oh 3,000 just before
launching his rap career donates $10
there good PR thank you Swiss oh shout
out to the chat let's keep it keep it
nice and friendly and clean all of our
mods out there helping out we appreciate
it
keep the chat on on on tasks all right
here we go here we go like that oh all
right they're gonna be one of these kind
of guys who just pokes and prods at
different weaknesses in my repertoire so
I'm going to focus and make sure I bring
out the big guns
the first time you play an opening
ah huh
okay
who is better and why
you
you're already losing here
just trying to I love when you get so
focused you know
that's what she said
yeah now I know this I know this I know
this stuff
good stuff
knocking it's good stuff just
no this is not right
I have to deal with this
ah
take your time what's the idea
you
okay I'm gonna try something very
ambitious and very dodgy I can't wait I
mean it disgusts me to the core but I'm
gonna try it
this is such a disgusting move I'm gonna
call your bluff and go get that Bishop
here oh I want it okay it's okay
you
you know this there's this famous saying
life is not about the bishop prayer
never heard it
okay I'm just going full body mode here
Wow
as big chest confined magnus carlsen
likes to say in such cases playing
against them and not against it oh man
classic the number one chess comm fan
magnus carlsen you forgot to say that
yes number one yes absolutely yeah
number one and everything now everything
he's never won and everything you're
right if you tell him like somebody
loves just woke up more than him he's
gonna jump at you and say no no no I I'm
that guy I'm the number one number one
you're right I think you're right
definitely no you just have to find the
right way to deal with him and then you
can bait him into anything
like you said you're playing the man
here not the position playing for the
fact that I'm much more likely to screw
up this position than anything else yeah
I mean there is some hidden screw-up
potential in his position that you might
not even realize but but I've got the d5
square I've got control over if I've
Square and you've got potentially weak
diagonal each one is as well I just need
like a couple of moves like Roque c1 and
I'm gonna be right there oh man I'm
gonna induce
am i probably not probably not a good
idea
let's be a little bit prophylactic here
better late than never as they say
[Music]
yeah
yeah but what's your next move like
what's the big deal
have you heard of term strategy strategy
if I heard of the term strategy so did
you know the beautiful thing about
strategy unlike tactics is that
yeah it's something
you know it's doesn't have to happen now
doesn't have to happen the next move
right will happen eventually to happen
eventually strategies become a word to
just justify bad plans in many ways
right just like don't worry about it I
have a strategy yes you speak more
broadly now you speak about American
politics I speak about chests oh man
it's so true though
Trudeau is Canada no judo is he's not an
American but he's a kind of died a
sudden why would you have to bring him
up
I'm gonna do something pretty okay I'm
gonna something pretty I'm gonna play
this move oh you know I haven't feel
like what was issued like the way I play
now I have a feeling we should have like
Hikaru watching us and that would be
really like go huge on Twitch because
it's very huge on Twitch when he car
watches two amateurs play I think I
think if we like we have Hikari here now
yeah if we had a car watching to him but
the views for the viewership for the
viewership I don't even know how to deal
with this right now do I appreciate do
appreciate incredibly gorgeous position
that I have it's just I'm just so proud
of myself it is one of my favorite
seriously it's just it's incredibly good
what I did I've got this beautiful
triple pawns I control all the squares
absolutely all the squares this is very
good it's very good I know I'm
retreating this is a very hearty karo is
her car was always watching so he's
probably commentating on this game right
now somewhere
um I I sort of didn't expect you to find
this more so this why I play Queen d7 it
does a bit inaccurate because I just
thought you're not gonna find oh I'm
gonna blockade the bleep out of those
dark squares baby you're not you're not
ever gonna fix those pawns without
sacking them
it's what I'm concerned I can see you
leaning in doing that thing where you're
trying to you're gonna try to find some
trick just swindle your way out of this
okay let's set it up there you go start
setting it up
yeah indeed
what I mean exactly tell me you don't
have anything but
but I'm you're get you're gonna put me
in that scared mode where I start
playing unnecessary prophylactic moves
you know this I've seen this whole
dog-and-pony dance before this whole
show
okay I'm the guy that keeps coming back
and buying a ticket for the same deal
hmm you
trying to do something tricky I feel now
in fact I am fine like regardless
because these two bones are great I just
tried to make you and deeper work so I'm
gonna just plain awesome
and go for the and go for the plan f you
know what that means well the famous
plan f
what is Plan F
we're gonna find out I guess there is
plan ABCDE and if nothing worse there is
funny
what am i doing yeah it's a very good
question but I've been wondering because
well yeah that was not the best by me
ah
I'm as yes time is now no I mean that
was the plan F all along plan flag
this up hugely as they say usually I
don't know why I said hugely with a
Scottish accent but I did hugely okay
what are you doing I'm gonna try to draw
you know so what they all say they all
say oh yeah this is no bad
mmm yeah it is the stage where I am sort
of
messing things up because I know I'm
gonna flag you anyway so I'm sorry
examples
you
oh snap okay
cambree sorry
it's going really sorry that you're
gonna flag me anyway something tells me
you're not that sorry
oh I almost checkmated you I wanted to
like no it wasn't gonna be made but I
wanted to put my 93 and then like scream
checkmate as if I thought it was even
though we knew you could go to h5 it was
a weird thing I did in my head there but
it was a beautiful a beautiful game by
the way no I'm just gonna make the cars
top ten list later
but like the position after move 21
you're screaming it's giant - yeah I
mean after like Bishop a5 EF Queen - -
if I start with Russia for their just
complete toast it's my dream for 20 -
yeah
instead it is just ya know I mean night
5 EF it was beautiful I slightly ruined
that with my yeah this position is
for my g1 anymore because you have f4
yeah exactly
yeah I sort of thought I'm not gonna
rush it but tonight you one of course is
stronger I have to refresh did we do for
ya once I got 91 and came around then I
was in better shape but still yes so
lying with this whole Bishop of six he
definitely
I didn't remember how I'm supposed to
polish this but yeah you should do
something a bit more direct I think I
don't know at what point maybe some
early h4 h5 for something like this
because yeah if I get the time to
reroute my bishop to c6 rook to g8 and I
got all the square so it's not so bad
yeah yeah I should have should have been
more aggressive there okay story of my
life well we've had some we've had some
interesting donations here and anyway
donated $10 and said he used to work at
Wendy's HQ in Ohio so I know how
valuable the Dave Thomas foundation is
thank you for raising money for this
fantastic cause awesome so you've worked
at Wendy's headquarters
you have Wendy's in the Netherlands no
but you don't have them in Georgia oh
yeah yeah so and when you visit the
motherland of SoCo you guys hit up the
Wendy's get that spicy chicken sandwich
I know because my we had like a wedding
Georgia and we invited a bunch of Dutch
guests and of course like the day before
like the day before they obviously went
to this fast food called Wendy's yeah
okay
yeah no there you go bad order from
there I mean instead of having all this
beautiful Georgian food they went to the
fast food I mean in Georgia it's
criminal to go to Wendy's but class okay
it's like what I have to pay with debate
with my kids to like go to a real
restaurant and all they want is
chick-fil-a or Wendy's and I'm like this
is ridiculous so I hear you on that um
so we had $10 there thank you so much
coming from a former Wendy's HQ Kentucky
donated ten Marshall donated 10 and then
cinnamoned donated $56 holy bejeezus
naps
it seems teachers like our total and now
there's gonna be going up there I mean
we've raised more than 78 I'm pretty
sure with that 56 Wow okay awesome
that's a big dough now here we go let's
rematch but I think it's I think this
donation is asking us to try to decode
the message behind because the 56 is a
very specific number say sensitive 76
okay I agree it's a weird number
Oh 56 dollars was converted from 250
Romanian dollars oh well there you go
and that said that does it Tim all right
well I rematched you
Oh bye but it doesn't work here like
that
how did you you could you can rematch in
the chat if you want I'm in the chat
yeah yeah one second oh yeah right very
much yeah sorry
all right this is where we turned it on
we is in the collective we all right
let's get a little more spicy here no no
no no no yeah let's do something do so
much good
this is naughty
this is so naughty
yeah
I'm not gonna grab anything you know
okay you're gonna go for this stuff huh
by the way how long a hope you got for
this section about 16 minutes but again
I the adoption process cannot stop
unless I win or draw if I if I break the
losing streak so we have 60 minutes of
five minute left but it'll go overtime
unless I can finish unless you want to
move to a faster control it's up to you
do you see the ninth xd5 is a trick or
you don't see it
d5 is sometimes a trick it's not right
oh that's yes sometimes a trick okay
no as long as you know that then we are
in the same page
okay I couldn't see my way out of this
trick
yeah
you
okay let's have some fun
don't even think that the exchange sack
is bad for me but
it's a very cool way to brag like I see
everything I see that there is an
exchange i see the whole thing i see the
whole thing i know exactly what you're
doing
shoutouts all the dough knows coming in
will love will get will get that shout
out in when the game ends
what are you doing you just you think
you can just launch an attack like that
no this is the diversion
I just want to trade bishops Hey go
succeeded that's just a diversion
you want one more diversion or not I
love diversions bring it on so the the
bishop trade
version
ha I actually see what's I trying to do
I don't like I actually I actually want
to launch an attack you see this is a
devil there's a double diversion I'm a
guy who all diversions work on because
I'm like squirrel squirrel like it's all
distracting to me
this is where the position has to get
nutty
yes Mike Robert has
you can't spell chess with
yes that's what they tell me
where is Robert has does he commentate
on our beautiful nature what's he doing
is he unemployed no one really knows
what he's ever doing that's the thing
who lives his life from one shot to the
other here
I think it prepares all these funny
jokes in between yeah right sit down
what the hell is that you think I will
take with a queen err what do you what
are you thinking I have no idea I'm just
trying to this is that this is no but
it's disrespectful this movie three it's
just disrespectful
now I mean if I'm not gonna play if you
continue like this I mean you hope I
take with a queen what is it what is it
you are trying to do it's just really
insulting
trying to figure out a way to launch an
unsound initiative and this is
absolutely epic what you're doing
I mean I've I've never lost I'm running
out of coffee here we have a real
problem
was that one of those hidden messages to
the production guy or yeah it's code
code you wanted like great we should
help borrowed name what for Jimmy Kofi
let's go around the office what no this
is code for bringing you more coffee I
guess oh that's the other way we don't
have an intern for coffee though you
know really don't have the ability to
flex that kind of power
you went for it I didn't think you had
the don't say don't don't say that word
please thank you hat please anything
yeah - go for it
I underestimated you well you know I
now I did it out of fear I was I feared
all kinds of things so I just took the
pawn because I didn't I didn't do it
because I'm brave I did it out of fear
very often people are brave out of fear
so that's fine right oh I mean yeah
that's that's it's kind of like you know
necessity breeze genius you know the
those most afraid act the most braver
was you could say that you could say
that about I guess you could say that
about me
I have very pretty move against one of
your moves so I'm just waiting for you
to make that move yeah but I'm fine to
continue waiting because I wouldn't mind
some yeah I'm waiting for that correct
correct oh yeah that was nice you are so
good at chess I don't care what acara
says about you
you are good so he cut okay I don't care
what Magnus says about you and eesh I
think you are pretty good yes
no Magnus everybody's oh my colleagues
they they respect me which is why I'm
able to compete with them it's easy this
is for you to get so many wins that
people can't make fun of you for draws
anymore this is your chance
I think I'm doing fine but it's but okay
rue Kato is protecting protecting the
very important bit upon
you
Oh everything about my life is getting
harder by the second
you
okay let's play for activity
gotta admit your mistakes this move
Ruger to was pointless
heeey
can I check what you're doing you should
always check
chuckle might be made
you
so many tempting options I don't know
you know
but I wanted it to look like I got some
pawns for all this mm-hmm that was my
goal
you
she's just that was the end
it's all she wrote I resigned because of
the fork
just to show everybody in g7 we have a
fork and if I go to h8 Bishop hang so
it's just honestly it's just it feels
abusive right now this is what I have to
do Oh got out we had a mr. dodgy
donation I don't think that's everyone's
favourite agenda-driven social media
troll I think that's actually a
different mr. dodgy you know are you
everyone's favorite social media troll
or as mr. dodgy chest taken that title
are you fighting with him about that
currently I like no no first let me make
a first move then I'll talk about this
very important question the French yeah
let's do the French I think I saw
everyone's favorite true well yeah
earlier okay you know you used you
started it yourself I mean you start
throwing out accusations here so let me
let me let me go back back at you I was
thinking the other day about the great
rivalry between two major chess
corporations yeah so you're talking
you're talking obviously about chest
chest chest chest those comment and
chose the just kids that come obviously
chest back and chest cube okay so let's
just say that I get what you're talking
about yeah what were your thoughts about
this existential crisis so yes
somehow I started linking things yeah
like there is that website and that
website there is let's say on one side
magnus carlsen on the other Hikaru
Nakamura
there is wrench on one side
younggu son on the other there is like
for every character you have they have a
character right for mr. doji you also
have a character in fact who's that you
fool well know who that is
but you also have that social media is
it you no no no no got me thinking in
fact that should there be a third
company then I'm might take a role of
like either Hickory or mango some more
likely over and Gustavson but anyway
yeah the only thing is I've even traced
like I've even traced the Nick Barton of
just 24 in fact so I go into really deep
into the comparison but yes just 24
right you're you're dancing around this
like it's a like it's a curse word or
something despite what you might hear
what we choose not to say is not
something that's forbidden that's just
the storyline they like to have about
just calm so but who is our
agenda-driven social media trolled
arrival mr. dodgy chess I need to know
who is this it is a it is a it's a
female character in your case
it's a female character in your case
is that enough hints for you or I'm
thinking about this um now who who is an
active I mean not really social media so
much as twitch probably but still oh
yeah I don't really know that it's it's
a fair comparison yeah I believe yes
various it can be I believe
yeah I mean I think there's anonymity
involved one way I think everyone knows
him mister but both no but it was not
the case at the start at the start they
were under limit it was involved like
the names was mutual it's just that
later mr. doji grew but that was a
mistake as well like he broke out of the
you know he broke down an enmity and he
slightly also he slightly over does the
I mean he doesn't do it for put the
money or anything but it's just that
here voices his support to to to
mainstream ish which make him less
underground yeah I would just I would
argue that chess players in it for chess
and she just happens to work very
closely with chess calm because that's
exactly
it's exactly what estimation into twitch
but I would also argue that Bay has like
given a lot more financially than just
social media tweets and Mister dodges
event coming up I think has like I think
it has bribery is one of the prizes so
that's a goal no but I mean I believe
the mr. Deutsch is also not there for
for the money or he's also going to
likely support yeah I mean it doesn't
have to it doesn't have to be like exact
same but there is some some sort of no
this is valuable valuable insight
because you're like you said you're
you're potentially leaving the third
rival company here so I think right now
is the most unbiased though which it
doesn't exist yeah but yeah are you
gonna sack
my god you are gonna sack I should I was
just choosing I was just choosing to
second a four or five but this is a bit
nicer I think
I actually played aged 5 just because I
wanted to see you sack that's why I
asked the question as I did it alright
fine what's gonna happen here what's the
one thing that the thing that happens
where d3 comes in and then I get in
trouble I've seen this whole thing
before
okay look how to buckle down there's a
chance this there's a chance that this
game gets crazy
even more crazy I think I don't I don't
think I can handle more crazy than this
I think this my absolute limit here
oh god this is a little complicated
there's a little bit complicated
that was my help
yeah because now you know I'll start
playing with myself yeah I'm gonna start
seeing things that you're not gonna be
seeing and if you like playing with your
hair is that like a really cute thing I
bet soap it goes that's not the playing
with myself without mints
yeah okay
that was a good move I know you don't
need the compliments but I just want you
to know that was a good move oh I have a
feel that reek by the way oh I have a
filthy trick what are you gonna do
oh you do have a filthy trick yeah but I
should have announced it
yeah there we go
all filthy announcer on tricks I should
have okay you are a lot more like me
than you realize I think because I think
you do have a flair for entertaining
even before good chess at times I think
there's a little there's no there's a
small little entertainer there inside
you Aneesh and I'm going to pull it out
we're gonna pull it out pretty soon over
time your chess entertainment is going
to become more valuable to you than your
chess moves you have to be careful it's
a very slippery slope
no I'm actually
I'm actually like trying to you know
survive
it might look like I'm trying to say I'm
just trying to survive
yeah this is really getting out of hand
Plan F Plan F and coming
playing flag
you should have me I should you should
clarify that otherwise people think
horse
I think like what kind of plan does he
mean I just means flagging because no I
think I have to go for this
which is a very bad sign for me I think
you could have sex in a better version
you could have like move the Queen to a
four and then I would win it and then
you would second but it doesn't matter
it's all in the game I don't know what
to do
I feel like you're purposely distracting
you know
and purposely purposely taking all your
pawns yeah that's another thing you're
gonna do purposefully purposefully yes
I have a lot of pieces for the Queen
but but so that becomes a but now yeah
but
like the queen is really good
to do here
it's a little bit late to do something
host would you do nice
yes uh wait a second
I have to flag you now
it's just stupid chisel come software
damn it oh man this is so much fun
oh no no no no no
how much time is left no yeah I didn't
even try to win that is avoided it times
out
I did it that is that is so incredibly
it is so incredibly clever that you know
but of course I I of course
first I clicked on the Queen then I
won't clicked on d3 but somehow it went
Queen 23 instead of what is you do there
you mouse I don't even feel about that
no but it's not it's not like it's not
even the mouse sleep it's like sometimes
you click on peace aha and then another
color somewhere and then you click on
the square but you didn't in like first
you wanted to play with the Queen so you
sort of clicked it then you released it
and then like few seconds later you
try to push g3 but it's sort of pushing
if you push the square and then the
Queen slide it right there
oh god this is ridiculous I would really
really like to blame the chess comm
interface for this like no no no no no
it's not nice it's just not the
interface it's just that but but I can't
is well yeah that's like no it's in my
instincts to throw everything I do under
the bus and self-deprecating want mr.
Dodge has to be happy right but I can't
do it here I can't do it here so we're
gonna take a very quick break when we
return a nice Giri tries to redeem
himself and adopt me in three minute
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
I'm that troublemaker I am not too old
we're not twice to move
I am like just remember I am NOT
unlovable find out more about what
children in foster care are really like
and help us find them forever homes
and we are back here once again the
adopted Danny may additionally is super
Grandmaster a nice giri here and we had
another donation that hasn't gotten a
shout out yet our a star with seven
dollar donations so we're up to one
hundred and fifty bucks
only a hundred away from our goal Anish
I think we're gonna get there now this
is the time in the show when people
start speculating on family trees and
bloodlines like and they wondered
someone in chat wondered if I adopted
you would that make em BL your
grandfather ya know there are many many
ifs in there I think so okay well this
is um I don't I don't want to even talk
about what just happened because as much
as I cannot feel good about avoiding
adoption I don't come on come on yeah
don't don't don't be with this kind of
we you know this one of these people who
start saying sorry after they beat you I
mean just you are happy just take it and
move on real quick reminder everything
being raised today goes to the Dave
Thomas foundation for adoption go to
Dave Thomas foundation org
and check it out so lots of fun
questions in chat thanks for being with
us everybody Aneesh and I haven't fun
this is uh
there's been a you know
fashion
show so far lots of fun topics
yeah no we definitely breaking the glass
ceiling very unsure breaking the third
wall as they say or so I don't know
someone said something one time all
right let's do it three oh all right I'm
gonna challenge you oh wow
now you're third on the list because
Hikaru is playing Peter Svidler is
playing oh there we go we lost all our
viewers in three everybody left okay are
screaming so everyone's gone okay there
we go
all right or or maybe we get some xqc
people here say what do you say
oh did I say I'm up for it of course you
guys to see people right there okay yeah
well I mean it's uh it's honestly crazy
to see the growth of chess right now
it's amazing by the way did you get my
challenge I just said it to you know I
have the issue of oh never mind at all
for sorrow and enforce the stuff on Mia
yeah I'm forcing our match because I
have the power to do that
it's pretty awesome no no oh
um okay let's do this let's do this
bloomin filled again and let you do that
crappy Bishop g5 one you just did let's
do it again
oh he doesn't want it he's avoiding it
oh wow this that's the thing in yeah
straightforward it's the thing
okay
you've got some top top I am preparation
area super exaggeration you've got some
top international master preparation
yeah
there's very deep very deep close
affinity team super international master
you
I might be slightly tilted after the
previous game so I have worn warning you
of that usually usually what I'm to look
it's not like I don't win it's just that
I win but very ugly so it's gonna be
very angry okay good that's what I want
I want it to get ugly oh let's see
remember all I need is a draw I'll take
on a worse end game what the heck
yeah good luck
yeah if you're just joining us everyone
Aneesh you know what he did you know he
he messed up big time at the end of that
time control I mean I can't make excuses
for anybody as much as I want to
the word endgame scared me so I just
went credit for running away
yeah it's so horrible if I have a such a
bad move but I am just completely
altered so I just want to get this stuff
over with
oh wow and you are get I don't say city
this round it's the first it's the first
game of this time control so I feel once
again less responsible for it you feel
less responsible for I love that
let's get the Queens off come on okay Oh
are you bluffing that you're hanging
that point you're so adorable that is
adorable doesn't work does it it doesn't
we're not gonna let you get away with it
oh Jesus I know not only not only that
but also you got your queen tray dinner
yeah good for you good for you they say
you are great they say you're a great
and game player and don't they you know
so much said that
what the do thing on the Chad by the way
Maxime is here Maxime is so bored
to the extent awkwardness Jesus Christ
Maxime get a life seriously
I understand there's there is Quran I
know that but do something do something
with your life I mean come on
but everyone watches the chess category
these days like you said right
and Carl was streaming me yes yeah no I
mean I must be honest I almost sometimes
doing such ridiculous things I like
watching a car and all that yes sir
it's really bad it's what boredom does
to you
what are you gonna do
some think
you
or am i doing that was dumb
did you have a wallet on one's snack
town population one yeah yeah
I don't even know
you
I think Maxime started watching the
moment he heard there is a prospect of
him becoming my grandfather I think
that's when he got excited okay I'm
sorry I'm really sorry there's gonna be
pure flag like yeah I know you're gonna
do things that your the thing is the
game that is sort of by accident removed
something yeah I just did that to gain
ammunition so that I can now flag you so
that I cannot flag you shamelessly in
every game is that about it yeah oh you
are playing not so bad I'm playing
pretty badly though
you
I don't do this time please hated
the king has nowhere to run
Oh keep repeating you know what happens
when you repeat too many times right uh
sure you're aware of that rule
I did it's so dumb I want to get that
position again okay I'll do it with
Bishop here Oh what's going on snap okay
sorry
here we go here we go now you're really
stuck
what are you doing
you
oh snap boom Shakalaka
watch it
oh no oh wait you're actually gonna flag
me
I thought I was the one up on time here
somehow
yep 0.9 that's that's how it's gonna be
now oh that was a backbreaker that's
just a hair now that's how we're gonna
play now oh man okay here we go there's
a server that's gonna bite you right
what now that we're here though you know
you're doing your sinking down to my
level
it's you're sinking down to mine ok here
we go now this is the first time you've
repeated now I know you're angry
we'll play this again
the French is not very good this does
the people on the opening
oh man it's for for our viewer from
France there
yeah
well so crazy thing about this line
then did I just get the same position
with two Tempe down there yeah
you
yeah I'm slightly tilted I must be
honest I am slightly tilted that I think
it's it's pretty obvious right there's
no point hiding that ya know you're not
doing well buddy mentally or emotionally
complete complete yield
it's really bad there's nothing I can do
about it it's not like it's personal
it's just I entered the state and then
yeah doesn't matter who is who is
opposite me how much I like the Gerson
just said as I said it's not like I
don't win I do win it's just that I've
been quite ugly yeah it's just not gonna
look good yeah I mean my even my
reputation my gotta protect my
reputation I've got a perfect reputation
and it's getting ruined here
oh wow
you
it's the kind of game in which the
typing and the background is going to
annoy me so please warn your producers I
don't hear the typing yeah sometimes I
mean I hear I hear it when the game gets
out of hand usually
you
I should play this opening
gives you too many chances
you
it is pretty low it's a beautiful
opening the French
whenever
makes you feel like if elope I don't
like this either yeah this little
i-square it's a lot of light squares
what's he doing I know it's bad what
would what would he can say about this
move you say you will not be happy yeah
what is Danny doing Danny are you doing
Danny I mean I know Danny is bad but
Danny what are you doing
is why people want no chat no chat no
chat no Chad house is a good player
Danny's bad no Chad go Chad Chad don't
make jokes about I know that no no Chad
stop
Jeff not okay Chad I get it I get it
no chatter I'm not trying to be funny no
jet no jet no jet thing
no oh thanks thanks for the tier 1
oh thanks for the tier 1 yeah I think
you're allowed to make fun of it Karl
because you're a super Grand Master
okay guys I gotta focus there so I've
got this pin going there
take stakes Thanks the thing about this
is it's actually a great complement to a
car because it means you've watched him
stream
I'm just now I'm just gonna flag him I'm
just gonna flag him okay
it doesn't matter really just you're
just gonna fall put it is just looking
for a checkmate oh my god checkmate yeah
I just checkmate
Hansen no hot no hands no hands no hands
is no chat or chat hands is a good
player cat hands is a good player okay
okay go one more GG yo go one more go
one more alright that's it okay
Barnet euphoric I'm gonna stop you right
now gotta get the bishop out nice III
okay Chad I'm just gonna do something
okay
F for Kobe should be five here 94 is
already guess this guy Knight of three
okay yeah he's six I'm gonna go you five
get the c5 phone there you're
highlighting hey Carl yeah this one is
highlighting ninety four so head
against I hit it against his gun ten
times yeah the c5 bones weak
am I gonna get thirty two hundred
thirteen hundred yeah I know very bad
rating guys I know sorry
very bad rating I know I know right I'm
better chest right I know I'm bad a
chest guys than bad just gonna go castle
castle
I got whatever I'm gonna cuss I feel
like you played better when you when you
act like a quorum believe it or not one
time one time I I should do it regularly
sometimes I think like what would Magnus
play or what would MDL play if it's like
a groom foot or something and then I
come up with a move and then it turns
out it's a very good move that's a very
good strategy it's a very good like it's
a generally good strategy like you
should try yourself
like try to play against me by thinking
what would I do in your face okay I'll
do that from now on are you provoking me
or you're just not seeing anything would
it be time is it it could be either one
it could be both probies both yeah it's
probably both
take stakes
you
scam barite can be right
I've just got takes and finished three
and it's not
you
I just hope someone's clipping this and
sharing
while he screams right now Oh Danny oh I
need an airplane
Oh Oh Jeff you want me to watch on you
son Danny playing Oh Joe Chad Chad you
you really you really want me or should
I watch xqc okay should i watch chicks
or sanitation Oh Chet Chet what Chet
what do you want what do you want yet
what do you want Chad Chad Chad what do
you want okay fine I'm gonna watch xqc
fine fine okay Chad fine I'm going with
you
he doesn't wanna play this you want to
play does he want to play now Chad Chad
does xec what up oh oh he doesn't wanna
play okay oh right now oh oh he's
playing him right now okay Chad okay
Chad go Chad do you see do you see or
sharp should I put myself in there in
the right corner or in the down corner
should I put in the left or Chad so what
do you want Chad what do you want so
what do you want
Oh Chet Chet Chet shall I should I water
su-sure what do you want what do want me
to order yet
b5 what was he 5
whatever okay Chat Chat Chat to shower
or sushi okay wait let me just let me
just play some with you yes what should
I order sushi Chad Chad I'm trying to
get you an egg gave a draw
look at that whatever whatever I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna flag him good chat
so I want I want some chicken fajitas
but you just what's this oh Jesus
Thanks Oh thankful and thanks 400
guys fix one other bids
okay what I'm just gonna flag him just
before got the c5 square got it got the
c5 square
all I have to do is draw you
did you also by the way notice the
Hikaru when he once it gets winning he
always has some song on the
background but once he gets a winning
position he starts to like jam to the
song but only when he has a winning
position not before and not after
you notice that I haven't I didn't know
I was hosting this show with the world's
leading expert on I thought I was the
world leading expert on the choral
behavior I'm learning I hey this is
now I study my hikairo in my free time
oh yeah yeah
I start to play also lucky card is the
problem it's really what I did
and I trade no
feel like you're about to swindle me I
just don't know how it's gonna happen
yeah that's there is that that's how
it's happening
what are you doing what is it what is it
what is it
okay okay Chad I'm just gonna flag him
again I'm just gonna have to flag him
guys I'm just gonna have to flag him
again oh man we're gonna flag me
and in second
Oh rap
this was a hickory game this was a
Hickory game guys
from start to finish let's winter
Chikara
one more GGO
Candace 36 no I'm just gonna play just
six okay c6 Caro
oh that's the same d5 that's my squares
going yeah I don't even know what to do
in this line he doesn't know what to do
we should for six I just take it takes
or whatever I'll just take takes takes
so he car decided to watch us instead of
xqc right I don't know this this this
proves that he car he still got some
soul left in him and it's not just about
the clicks and the views but he just
genuinely curious what are they doing in
this small little crap show of Danny and
Anisha and it's not for him about the
views anymore it's just about his heart
his passion and I appreciate that he
Karim
I appreciate that I don't even know if
he's watching us so
oh it's it sounds creepy but I heard
someone saying that he's watching us
you
Danny please seek our watching please
play faster and better not the usual
stuff
you want me to play good moves because
he car was watching he's also my dad he
adopted me and bullet on a random show I
think xqc was actually watching that
what am I supposed to do here
please play at the White Sea Cara will
move on and which the ecstasy show
instead to black hole this is just too
slow whatever guys watching
Chad they want me to keep on watching
Oh b5o be fine I think Danny's gonna get
roasted here in the King out okay Chad
just gonna go a five a four
please also appreciate how my chest
style just gradually
gradually change into Icarus like now we
move like be 596 into seven they just
come instantly to me it's wonderful
wonderful concepts
I hate my position so much Oh Oh and I
owe that that's actually a good move oh
that's actually a good move
[Music]
it's actually a good move I might have
to focus here in five
five
okay
I'm just gonna open up the position I
think
I'm just gonna open up the position
Shadia when we talk about the position
or not
[Laughter]
I'm just gonna open up the position I
think Chad he's gonna opposition with a
4mm okay that's got c4 square
I've got a good night there
shed you want me to drink from the cup
check they want me to drink from the cup
what I want to do no no no mods mods
look what he said mods can you please
remove the guy he said that I should
drink from the cup no nobody said not
water yeah
once okay thanks thanks
Chad please don't say I'm weaker than
Magnus or I'll have to mod you out of
here now please don't say I'm we
couldn't Magus Chad please no chest
please no Chad please don't say that
another Ugandan Magnus is just
psychological types of psychological
feel like you're psychologically
tormenting me right now
you
we both know how it's gonna intern
you're gonna flag me that's good it's
one of the many ways to converting this
position probably the previous way
ah
you
this feels like this feels I don't know
what torture really feels like but this
feels like it has to be close
this is this is what it would be like
now I'm just giving you the experience
of what would he care adoption show be
like the kind of game this is the kind
of game you would lose to Hickory
what was so wrong in that game I don't
even know I was just distracted by all
of your Hikaru impersonations that's
what no no that's not seriously Denny
it's just it's an excuse I would also
use in your shoes but it's just the
position there's just a strategic
remember we spoke about strategy at the
beginning I mean we can we can pick up
the conversation right here I mean this
is one of those examples of like the
long-term vision that I have you know
the long-term vision and the only way to
disturb that vision is by you trying to
do something funky and if you do nothing
funky it will just happen how I see it
from the start you understand so
this house is how I feel right now right
now okay all right here we go here we go
yet I'm not gonna order anything by the
way I like your Flair there
I like your Flair with the icon
there with the icon yeah the black king
so I hope your car yeah no this is a
wonder watched many hours of him could
impersonate him like you are right now
no I'm not actually impersonating I'm
just literally coping transportation is
the sincerest form of flattery so yeah
and I'm just literally coping there
well hey course I'm watching you right
now is there a news clip oh oh is it
gonna be
is it gonna bring me any more or more
people or I sure just watch it okay yeah
I'm just gonna watch it
I'm just curious Chad please don't leave
me please come back I'm gonna watch it
right next please come back
please share please come back no don't
leave me chat or you don't know who
anisha's I was doing of one issues
actually not yet though he's like no
Chad he's not he's not from overwatch No
no I don't think I need plays
counter-strike no I don't think so the
Sakura play counter-strike now No
I don't think it does kind of strike
still exist even
you
it's a bad sign I'm slowly running out
of the chicory juice so I of the juicers
so I start playing like myself gonna
give you chances
you
dancing queen
do you think a car will remember us when
he's the biggest streamer on Twitch
uh you you speak to your chest of calm
fellow investors or or I mean he's he's
on his way he's on his way to being not
just the biggest chest streamer now I
mean as long as he keeps a little bit of
chess going I'm happy for him just a
little bit of chess
because what matters in the end told me
the other day I was teasing him about
about some streams and he said and he
was like I was like you're gonna be the
ninja of chess and he was like forget
the ninja of chess you know just be
ninja and ya know exactly but I think he
should I think we good I thought about
it and I realized he's not wrong I mean
he's literally no he's not wrong but he
might gain like ten more thousand people
but if he loses me you know if he loses
me
it's gonna break him yeah I think he
should from time to time still
provide me with the content you know the
content that I deserve that I need I
think that's what it's about it's about
balancing between these 30,000 people
and me I I will definitely tell him that
because you might say that okay at some
point I'm going to watch
the xqc thing
I might but it's not what I came for
you know I came for the for the good
moves
I came for quick good news
and I might stay for ecstasy but I want
my quick good moves back from time to
time sometimes I don't even know who
you're speaking for anymore
what do you mean I'm not I'm not paid by
anybody I'm just sticking my mind know
what's wide has to be also commercial
with your people I mean why do you think
I think nothing has to I'm the only one
who's paid to saving me and Magnus me
and Magnus are the only ones loyal
are you trying to say that are you
trying to say that you are as greedy as
Magnus because I think Magnus is the
greediest I think I think he wants to be
the best at absolutely everything Magnus
is number one and everything as far as
I'm concerned now if you want to take
that number one greediest spot from
Magnus you're gonna have to work hard
for it I gotta fight
so oh my god you I think a niche finally
knew how to just break me not that he
needed it but I just I can't even my god
now I'm blundering the night
Oh Mike I just wait do I have a chance
that you blunder the Queen just let me
get a queen no especially for you I'm
gonna put a horse on c1 okay I mean and
I should I appreciate the position looks
a little better now it looks a little
better for me than it would have I
appreciate that
GGO gg yo the I feel like I'm completely
we've had more donations Sam tan with 25
Nord or maybe he made a typo and meant
to type Mordor I don't know but he he
also came through with the 5 bucks we're
getting closer to our goal thank you so
much
you know we okay here we go you're
finally let me played my bad openings
finally
it took you all day to let me play this
mmm-hmm is there a way out of here or is
too late
what oh five what's that yeah it's bad
that's my whole point that's my jam
you
there is usually a trap yeah I mean
usually these lines they have
some point like if you make a move like
a Bishop e7 that comes queen g4 and then
you're happier yeah there's always some
kind of trick here that's usually the
point yeah that there is like the most
natural move as bad
and the rest are just very good this is
where
we give you a chance
you
do you know that I've got exactly the
same Mouse as a cigarette
you have the same mouse as a coral exact
exactly the same does he know that
he doesn't have to know that you have to
know that I mean did you buy it because
of him
now you put me on the spot come on tell
the truth you
hikaru I think it's a little bit like
naming my son Danny because of him but
it is despite that it's not a good
reason to switch which to me is the
biggest compliment I've ever gotten in
the world right you didn't named your
kid after me yeah you also didn't change
the name because of me yeah yeah I mean
I knew I knew of you when my son was
born and I still made my son Daniel
which right you took the risk something
I mean
the chat loves you by the way our chat
or the chant the chat chat what he won't
chat what do I'm into the ok chest BAE
in the chat just confirmed that you
asked what mal Socorro uses so you're
busted
no I actually asked what Mouse did ask I
think I asked what Mouse I should use to
my Instagram chat and my Instagram she
had said one of the members of my
Instagram chat basically told me what
Mouse he car uses and that just went for
it okay
by the way Tommy Shelby just donated 48
dollars
oh and Daniel ranch has donated in
exchange
yes we have
we have all the new legends showing up
in chat because they've heard of the
number one in car Nakamura fan and east
Giri giving impersonations
that easier there is just in personality
current you have all the glory
she's a sure your job doing your choppin
it did you start using your brain
finally oh what's happening
I think sighs I think you've lost your
mojo when you stop making fun of her car
oh you need to go back to being you know
Shh
you
nobody bad because I'd be totally busted
here I wanna I want a bunch of games
yeah I want like five games now just so
I'm clear dab of Jesus
you saw it unbelievable unbelievable
absolutely couldn't believe that you
would see this move
let's go
nice carry you might be winning the
hearts of fans because not many people
have the the gumption you know to make
fun of hit karu but you're right now
you're losing the chess game and I love
it I love it
yeah I suppose so Oh God
hey good news for you you still have 11
minutes to start a new streak okay
in a way I kind of wasted that victory
why I should have made it the last game
of the of the thing well I mean the
moment you can also choose one to win
it's the moment I should really quit my
job yeah yeah come on is Maxime still in
the chat Maxime give your son some love
I think I think you could donate some
bits for that victory
maxime doesn't know what bits are he the
only word he knows it starts with the B
is a baguette and there is one more
there is one more B word that he knows
but that's we had just made just made
donated fifty bucks
you know why because chess pay is your
number one fan Aneesh I know if you knew
that she wants you to stream
mmm she wants everybody to stream but
she does and it's fantastic
when she doesn't make me feel exclude
exclusive enough he doesn't you want you
want her to make you feel even more
wanted no I mean like if yeah if she
wanted only me to stream whoever she is
I mean it doesn't have to be a she or a
him it just it's not no it's not it's
not a gender thing it's like if that
person wanted only me to stream I would
understand but if the person wants
everyone to stream and I'm just one of
those many people
so happy I won that last game I don't
even care what's going on anymore
it's the same same here but it's like
the reverse I don't care what kind of
anymore
me upset about the oh yeah that was so
sweet I found that Queen a 3 I hope
Magnus is watching well someone clip and
send that to Magnus tell him that I'm
the number one player of playing Queen a
three moves
how was Magnus gonna beat that he wants
to be number one and everything and how
does he beat that yeah III really don't
know that's right no I think though
Magnus was computer it has some software
that it blocks all that just with corn
footage comes his way and just like he
sees an MC board he doesn't see anything
all right he says can you please convert
converted into some other website and
then like at least I just yes you just
donated my dad lvl and guess who's not
my dad yet if you thought the storyline
of this show was gonna end up being
three men and a baby it's not right now
Aneesh has not adopted me yet it's a two
and a half menu right now it's only two
and a Half Men
how much did maximum donate because I
thought here's a very expensive
apartment and yeah that sounds about
right here I'm gonna donate six by the
way by the end of the show what is what
is he doing hey go chief can I go G for
takes takes takes Bishop g3 no G for any
blunder g4 g for takes takes a tribute
305 knight of seven takes he just won a
G for you just under G for
I'm just I'm just I'm just gonna go for
it whatever I'm just gonna go for it
g4 go for it
dancing queen dancing queen cafè has a
donut is your uncle I'm small King this
guy I'm smoking this guy you she must be
she must be enjoying the the fun here
yet I don't know why he's still playing
I think you should resign yeah Chad I
think you should resign knows
I'm bad I'm bad you know bed I'm bad I'm
bad
here bad I'm still playing like yes yes
yes add as much as Michael Jackson thx
Michael Jackson
Oh
chip can I just play it okay can I just
go be should be wait wait he came
blundering this I know then he can be
wondering this should be 5tj check can
you chase but I've got Ruby six in the
end wait look look so we should be five
king Jade check King h8 takes Ruger six
takes
GGO are you doing easy do you know hey
Carlos watching now
GGO check I'm letting you make me takes
break are was sake
come on that night of seven yeah I'd be
play the fun date
okay okay we go again go again next ya
guys to 3019 yeah it's a very miserable
rating guys I know I know it's very
musical ready chat not yet I know it's
very miss already no chat
play that Scotch again
nice question didn't work well probably
you are a very bad positional player so
I'm gonna play this guy there's a
positional Bank
tim's candy hi guys it's me John yeah
it's like they are they're rolling out
this giant I shouldn't be saying that
yeah okay whatever this a bit too much
problem even for my Sanders
I don't know where you would go with
that but I can't wait to find out
eventually just hypothetically say that
you've got a world number one basketball
player rolling out a video lessons on
how to play basketball and then you have
like a promo video of that where there
is like some international master
basketball player who's gonna fill up
the whole video with like of like five
to ten minutes and there's not gonna be
any footage of that basketball player at
all
that's quite weird no do you want to
promote or you say it was almost like
also advertising then advertising was
correct it's just that it's just dumb or
advertising because you are advertising
the greatest basketball player but
you're not even showing him in the ad
like why didn't you bother filming him
into the ad as well now
there's just my thoughts but anyway I'm
not a big basketball fan so it doesn't
matter
I'm so and I should by the way I am by
the way not the team's candy player here
I am totally scanning it up here
completely
it's candy is really not for me yeah I
got a gut roll with the punches oh so
bad
yeah
you're not a team scandi player I'm John
I'm gonna kick you off the team off
teams candy
yeah
it's an interesting analogy you made it
I wonder if one better marketing thing
would be to put like I don't know the
face of this famous basketball player on
some sort of you know like a coin or
something some sort of currency on some
sort of coin no that's good that's good
also it's what is what is good marketing
is when you have a video course of some
international Moscow International
master bus to a player that says play
like that world number one basketball
player right well in fact you that world
number one basket player does not take
part in that course that is clever
advertising yeah so quite well
but the other thing is especially
because every basketball game ever
played once it's played is free right
exactly although you can't redistribute
it without the express written consent
of the National Basketball Association
but don't you think chess players would
love to go I mean this is totally
hypothetical but do you think chess
players would go for a company but let's
say I don't know tried to lock down all
games PG ends and make them not free do
you think chess would support a company
like that like the NBA
[Music]
yeah it's a good question I think some
even argue that the chess games are
should be rights of just players yeah
yeah because they are the artists yeah
but I don't know this like you could
argue for that there is an angle
logical angle you could argue for that
some have tried to argue for that right
yeah yes I think they do are you uh are
you being sharp right now or you are Hey
just talking hi guys it's me John
oh you are sharp okay yeah yeah big just
shaking I'm just shaking if your system
wait you're gonna flag me all right guys
this is where admissions this is where
I'm Nisha's entire plan backfires
and you are really on fire right now
you
come on
what come on what
work with Daddy here
oh this is such a big mistake you made
I'm the greatest end game player
of us to hear
oh I'll slit uh-huh
heard that before no no no time
you
you dirty dog dancing cui
GGO next next next keep going keep keep
going
first of all can you just acknowledge
that I beat the tar out of that scandi
for team's candy can you acknowledge
that I beat the living crap out of that
yeah you have to ask John for alright
that's it you know what I can smell
though on you know what the level the
level at us is going down
I'd beat you here right once yeah you
did I'll play differently yeah but I
don't remember how that game went so
it's okay
they also did it
you
we need some artists move Queenie eight
it's always so scarier I don't know why
but like when people play Queenie eight
I'm just my parents are immediately
feeling up stuff
don't know you know we're doing
something right now Jonathan core blood
just subscribed you even know who
Jonathan core blaze
No
you problem
he's like
you
did we just switch from one zone to the
other so quickly
is that even the obvious when it comes
to my John's that's nothing wrong haha
Ellis come
right let's just go for something nasty
here
I believe in the dynamic potential of
the Blumenfeld gambit
where did you read this smart phrase
that's a lot you came up with it
yourself we even dynamic so many words
so many so many words that I'm not
supposed to know yeah
dynamic potential where did you read
about that
I read about dynamic potential in a book
called dynamic chess strategy by Suba
well you read books I thought you're
only into the online things did you have
you read that book no no I think I
I know a book of subha but hey whatever
but I have to focus on flagging yourself
maybe I know yeah I I don't know if
Subaru wrote more than one book but I
have seen a book of him
maybe they stupid did write more than
one book but the dynamic
I read some it was even some sort of
opening book I don't know nothing about
Hedgehog could it be or not
be
yeah got to do something with inventing
potential of my extra point you don't
you don't have a lot of dynamic
potential here
let's distract you a little bit down
best thing to do is distract me
whoa is this that's called dynamic
potential unleashed
I know Asians can feel unleashed yeah
is that gonna be like the title of your
autobiography or is it more like dynamic
then I'm potential Anisha or unleash
maybe it was Shawn
yours is dynamic potential unrealized
[Laughter]
well I mean how many people still make
fun of you for for drawing lots of games
you know this statistically you don't
even draw many more games are you this
are you this desperate Danny are you
this desperate right now really you're
this desperate this you're gonna do the
under the belt thing to me right now
this is not school day three not school
I don't want you look at your moon three
pawn is loose yeah that's what she said
you know which one of yours is loose you
have no loose pause left because I'll
pick them all up
you
oh you're starting to realize your
dynamic potential
yeah
like it
ha
you just looked at the clock now and
thought can I fight him no you cannot
with good thinking
good thinking there buddy
check-check
here
boom
you
ah
GGO
Jiji
she's gonna try and flag me not gonna
try to flag me
all right he went on go again times okay
all I have to do is get a draw or win
and your current streak is over but your
honor
I mean your own kind of a downer right
now I want to downer but what is my
streak how many I have
I'll wait I lost one at some point so
what is how many I have you have three
three okay
yeah the c4 move is currently a little
issue let's see
oh this of course I'm doing the world
elite in a favor here by exposing your
your bad repertoire
yeah I mean I forgot just that you
played this f3 against an either if it's
a joke of course it's a complete joke
you don't remember the bad position you
got out of this yeah but it has nothing
to do with the
the opening
I think it had to do with the torchon on
v6 slightly misplaced
I'm not sure I don't even remember
you
so will you tell all of them you don't
even remember
is that your usual excuse I don't even
remember yes wrench we got you drunk
driving it guys I don't even remember
mister wrench
we saw you urinating on a tree um in a
park um I don't even remember you're
really not playing these nighters very
well these days like just in general in
your career in my career you know career
is fine I think my career as a whole is
okay but this game is not not a
testament to that
let's just say if this game would
reflect my career I should quit yes for
sure
I bet you didn't see that move coming no
I don't look at such bad news
you
okay flabbergasted here with this move
yes thank you
[Music]
know what to do what's the easiest way
to flag you
Jesus
you
your level has improved is your
anti-cheating software working there
[Laughter]
because you are just a twenty to
twenty-five hundred traded I am and your
level is suspiciously suspiciously good
I agree so I would like to you know I
would like to have a some call with you
to be honest yeah our organization also
can I have a zoom call with Danny wrench
please because I find it highly
suspicious and if he refuses to zoom
call I'm going to just kick him out of
here
and we'll do this
yeah it's either blue blonder Ambattur
it doesn't go it's one of the two shoes
all right he's your poison okay
Nitin Nohria I want to deal with this
now you're getting a little bit you're
doing that thing you did to me last time
which is what the when you start to
undiscovered in 80 pieces for no reason
for these bad night worse and then
I'm just how a meal does it that's how a
meal doesn't know
MVL has never played a bad night or even
his life how dare you
as they say in France show
I'm so afraid of wandering right now
I have you on the edge of your seat whoa
what does Grenache Donna couldn't do
anything
that was a suspicious move by you we
also measure when someone is just
playing so bad that it seems unlikely
that they're actually themselves uh-huh
there's such thing yeah
and you're
we're kind of on pace for that right now
now I'm on pace
you
Oh what am i doing
oh my rook was hanging and you didn't
take it I don't care don't care that
would be cruel
you
that's all you are
No aah yeah I want to take a shower
after this game whoosh wait it doesn't
feel good to win that way does it now
you know how I know it feels fantastic
it's like watching a horror movie
afterwards you just feel so icky yeah
oh this is yeah but I've got to think
what to handle there I don't know how
you got out of that oh I'm so bad I'm so
bad what happened there it just kills
one of the best ways to make my level of
play go up is to keep playing the night
or Finglas attack
I love these positions how did I blow
this so I should just play d4 right away
probably and disconnected that
yeah this plan was not ideal for me but
I mean you're analyzing the game or what
you're completely winning though oh yeah
I was just trying to figure out where I
went wrong but all right here we go here
we go
no time everywhere you went you went
wrong everywhere okay what do you mean
did you see the game okay you were like
is something you're gonna do now are you
gonna start playing the London
yes it's usually the sign of things
going downhill in someone's career
tell that tell that to everyone who's
playing London how much much by the way
yeah isn't it the thing that can amplify
but you blundered it it's sort of thing
I think shouldn't be blundering it I
think wait did I just wander that you
did
what the hell are you doing
what hell is that I'm just playing bad
moves right now man you are completely
tilted my friend that's what you are
you can't get over the previous game can
you mr. Harris doesn't it it still hurts
I can't get over this loss you're still
you are still thinking about that
Lillian game aren't you a little end
game of her ten minutes ago because
those are the games I have to at least
raw if I'm gonna not get adopted that's
why it's frustrating what I mean those
aren't the games there's not gonna be
many that we thought was the game yeah
if I can get you to blunder sometimes
I'll all people into feeling sorry for
me
and that's not the case here but blunder
blunder due to other motivation it's
possible this one because I feel sorry
for you that's not it's not on the cards
you are a very strong player just
sometimes you try to lose instead of
trying to win
that's just oh man all right I want to
result I am I'm still shaken up by that
last game okay let's go fastball Dan
what's this how many did I win there Oh
for now that's either five or six
probably fine and just a reminder if you
want to complete an adoption we can move
to bullet because that this shows going
to go over time and I know you're on a
tight schedule
that's scheduled so we can stay in three
minute or we can go to bullet and your
winning streak can carry over to bullet
that's your choice uh-huh I'm saying
that not because I'm afraid of you in
three minute I'm saying that to give you
a choice because I know again at some
point you got to put you know little
Daniel please can please stop talking
and start playing okay if that's what
you're into that's what I'll do you're
trying to talk you're just trying to
talk me into some kind of a nasty deal
this is not good for me I don't even
know what to do yes that's what you this
that's what the CEOs do well I'm not the
CEO dude I'm the CCO the chief chess
auditor oh yeah yeah because I'm the
most unqualified person it's just calm
so they made up a title for me yeah yeah
that's what you always say
that's like in goofy corporations where
CFO means chief fun officer mm-hmm
that's exactly what I am
I'm the chief fun officer
can people hear our producer or not yeah
that was him but can they hear tomorrow
yes yeah they could they're yeah
normally no normally they can't hear him
or the typing but in the case there he
was delivering an anecdote we call that
breaking the third wall I think we call
it sometimes he feels that he feels a
joke is worth it and he just right
shares it with people okay okay I love
how you like I'm you're kind of like
mush you're old you're kind of like a
four year old who doesn't always
understand sarcasm so literally explains
it out no just a toy that joke would not
cross the threshold of having to unmute
yourself but that's good that's good
feedback for my producer thank you I
think
I mean I'm nothing personal it's just
this is risky so the other day in my
kitchen my 14 year old I know what
you're thinking I have four kids yes I
do
my 14 year old broke the blender you
won't know how the blender was on and
there was a strawberry stuck in the
blade and so he shoved a knife into the
blender while it was going hey all of us
are in the kitchen he does this the
knife shoots we're lucky no one got
killed right it breaks the ministry
Shawna's brand-new Ninja Blender
so now Sean is upset because I you know
we got this new ninja it's broken so a
couple days go by we've been making fun
of Nash this whole time about you know
breaking the blender um and then at some
point sean is looking for it and she's
like god I wish I had the blender and me
and my other son are making fun of Nash
and we're like yeah what happened to the
blender weren't the blender go you know
naturally sarcastically we're making fun
of the situation but my four-year-old
who doesn't understand sarcasm goes dad
what happened to the blender was Nash
stuck a knife in it while it was running
can you believe he did that like
literally explains the whole joke
because doesn't understand sarcasm sorry
I just wanted to show him really
probably if a person listening to this
joke
didn't blunder a fat g5 phone haha it
would he would think it's funny but
[Music]
first I'm gonna tell you a joke and you
ruined it
but now now I start appreciating the
joke a little more because yeah position
is improving when you've wondered that
porn of over girl I saw the whole line
to the end and I just thought that in
the end there is going to be something
maybe and I thought the odds that you're
not gonna make it to the end are also
quite high but yeah this calculation was
wrong on many levels
okay
in many positions I make an assumption
that you're not going to find the best
move but it's just a very bad assumption
because then you always find it
it's not the worst assumption
I mean my position here I mean some in
some positions you have to make that
assumption in order to maximize your
winning chances but
can you tell one more can you tell one
more joke for like 35 seconds I'd liked
you hmm and you'd like me to wouldn't
you
Oh
crap
we do this the cleanest way
yes
you
into that
I'm doing it part stick
holy smokes how do you see that that is
absolutely insane
ah
come on oh yeah baby push em baby
you
yes yes I do a flagged you oh my god it
feels so good to do something so wrong
oh oh man oh man how is it's both
possible I mean I pre moved everything
how is it impossible you know who else
pre moved everything ah so that's
I'm robbing you baby Anish guess who
just avoided adoption in both blitz time
controls
now I just want to trace the sorry I'm
just want a book so I have the Queen
City I have one point two seconds you
know on a server on the server the pay
you if you think imma feel bad for you
you are wrong I mean look at this
position earlier look at this position
earlier I have found the most brilliant
I basically blacked out and played all
the best moves on the board and crushed
you with these pawns like that was not
even me but I did it no dead lost
you're dead loss okay I have a look for
a queen that should be more than enough
for me to convert much time does a pre
move take from one second point one this
isn't this is Lee chess where you can
pre move forever and not lose any time
okay if you want to play video games go
back in pieces okay if you want to play
chess you comfy chess calm but alright
Duke zero point zero point four and zero
point three as well from me at some
point this is your 0.4 0.3 I mean you
you you've lost a point second cuz in a
real game and have a plank until it
loose and I'm looking at your playing
boy you would lose at least point one
second that's our philosophy and they
make up where am i letting you make
multiple pre moves a point one is
alright but I lost point three sour okay
fine fine maybe even pre move on that
maybe I did primo if it's fine you know
what I'm gonna do right now I'm gonna
pre move our way to a break I just pre
moved oh if anything I just want you to
know this even though you may not be my
dad at the end of the day it does make
me love you more will be won't take a
break we'll be right back
[Music]
you
Anish
hi just by the way before we start the
bullet adoption just to be clear yeah
I'm of course kidding yes look like I'm
I mean it's pathetic game that I played
and I don't deserve to win it so I'm
just kidding and I had too little time
to fight you so I just don't take it
personally obviously because you might I
might seem like some kind of guy who
cannot stand losing and stuff it's just
that I mean I it was very fair I'm just
sorry about my knee here and we move on
okay no one thinks that about you
everyone loves you I'm just I'm just
telling you sorry in advance for what's
gonna help with you in bullets so just
exhaustion let's move on got it
okay okay challenge accepted
bullet portion here we go
quite literally challenge accepted I
will I will start games who had white
last I had white last so you get white
first a nice giri daniel wrench 1 Oh
boom
we go alright this is where it gets why
am i playing a Kings Indian you've
already thrown me off my game
the thing about boy is you can just do
bad things
naughty things naughty things
you
that's the thing
really
you
ah
also the level of my chest is gonna go
up dramatically because this is time
control I can actually play
I just don't think that's true
absolutely true
like I'm gonna start playing like some
real good stuff some strat strategy the
remember that word we learned and the
first time control yeah
the strategy word I wanted to say that
my dad taught me that word but then you
didn't deliver so
shoots okay this is where despite your
best efforts you come up short
and it almost works
you found the best move I hate when you
do that
ah all right all right fine fine you won
the first bullet game money
friggin dot okay here we go
good time sometimes like home when I'm
nervous
sometimes I'm nervous when I home I
don't know why I thought that was so
funny but I did
so the bullet does to you
like it's like a laughing gas
we call it the nervous laughter nervous
laugh check
did I do what are you doing I don't know
I don't know I don't know what I did I
don't know what should I say ever know
what you're doing I'm still okay it's
completely within the within the realm
aquatex the for was this sim similar
what are you doing
I don't know I just minor minor brain
minor brain collapse there very brief
you
I almost play queen d8
oh you're gonna flag me
you
Oh
aha you dead
Josh shenanigans I'm not gonna stay here
okay not gonna say I'm not gonna say
anything I'm gonna say anything
I'm gonna say anything will you promise
me anything no no no promises I'm not
gonna say anything okay okay can I say
something
no um I was gonna say if you if you
adopt me will you promise to give me the
shush finger I'm so into that Jesus
oh man will you give me the shush finger
baby oh I see what you are trying to do
here but it's I'm not blinking it was a
normal time was normal it was a normal
game
you had a taste of your own medicine it
was fine you liked it too
was all right
now don't start maneuvering now it's
ridiculous it's bullet
you
[Music]
come on blunder
there's nothing to blunder they're like
three pieces on the board and I own all
of them and the end abort
well you can do it you can mess this up
I believe in you
darn it
our net
you
or there's a night there's a way oh crap
okay resigns I have to admit you're
faster than I thought you were
I tell you it's my time control you have
no chance
you
okay
I'm just gonna keep making some bad
moves and see what happens
you
same thing that last time happened
oh man
that was a sick burn by you
you
hell yeah
mm I'm getting squeezed I think I found
your weakness yeah it's just we're each
other it's Jess yeah well it's that
simple huh
yes as a joke
was it Joann
Oh an ice queen there buddy oh she's not
her happiest right now he's a little
frustrated with let me go straighter let
me call her
I'm getting abused alright okay I have
to avoid this is my first chance to
completely avoid adoption oh come on
give me two half-hour we still have 21
minutes left apparently yeah okay so
there's no chance
what am i doing a Timberwolf likes so
bad
sense anymore
I am I here
[Music]
this is I just I'm not happy
what's wrong
what's wrong as I'm falling apart
thanks for
one tilt
I don't think it's still the things that
just killed
it's just the chess killed there's a
just so bad for me
everything about this hurts
you can't tell by my face I'm in pain
hmm Howie Oh
okay you didn't play the best move there
I wanted to take and I like to prolong
these games okay
I mean you're doing great take on these
six and prolong the game
you could have just taken on e6 and
prolonged
shorten avoid where's the fun in that Oh
Eugenio you were this close to
blundering of Perpetual no nothing too
close
sorry I see these professionals they're
in my system I support them from miles
away so I sit all right what does he got
now five
you
I'm literally just messing around
I just had to bait you
she baited
come on come on
I'm assuming that I have something here
assumption is the mother of all what do
they say about it I was assuming I would
have something here but she's the most
awful no screw-ups I think as the burger
is the full assumption is the mother of
screw-ups
no but that's the you know the Hedgehog
for you
hwoonk yeah well bullet is is late not a
lot of time to break down the
old-fashioned Hedgehog huh Wow look at
that good to catch you in a pre move
buddy
times I do bad things
this was very naughty but I'm not the
I'm not the kind of guy who I don't
remove these things I know better that
you cannot do spacious now I don't be
sure you can appreciate me
I just don't do it
I don't permit the that small chance of
that happening excluded
you
you're like a tennis player
you're you're really into the grunting
are you
oh yeah what are you into Danny stop
here you said you were into the Gro
thing you know why don't just players
make more noises when they play uh how
many how many games Suzette's uh-huh
we'll call this call this chinnis uh
ah
then I don't think you need the sounds I
think people get enough with the visuals
here ah yes well this is fun
oh crew I was crushing you
not even close not even close your
position so bad as against your position
your position barely got worse than a
minute than a second ago you've still
got all the Trump's risen enough I don't
care about this attack attack is an
attack is a myth you're
[Laughter]
you're a draw huh no no no no what I was
just making a joke
you repeated three times it was not for
three or four three oh if I twist your
fault okay I won't even count that like
we're just gonna keep playing oh you see
eighth is a three or fold oh I just gave
two checks on c1 let me see oh okay I
just wanted to make a joke okay fine
let's go continue oh fish you just made
the joke of a lifetime against yourself
even when you're winning you snatch a
draw from it I mean yeah no I just I
just did a joke there an expensive one
okay let's go what are you doing oh my
god I wanna I'm gonna let your streak
stay at seven I really feel bad for no
no no no no no uh I can still do it
right amount of time he's still time you
got 14 minutes yeah here we go okay then
let's do it all right Irie matched you
let's go yeah all right let's go let's
go
oh my god that was so funny I cannot
rematch all right here yeah oh my gosh
everybody is happy about that everybody
yeah
you know I just try to be tried to be
funny but it's bad idea yeah you tried
to be too silly you know I've made that
mistake before yeah
but it's actually a very very weird like
it's not a 3-fold because of the check
but because the Queen goes back and then
it's like it's a very weird one it's
really weird you know it was
it had me totally shocked actually I
really didn't understand how it was
through fault
ah
and no matter how long you think you
cannot find the night xt5 here
oh crap God why do you have to humiliate
me like that 95
they're like so long tonight I was I was
thinking you are finding it but I was
sitting there thinking like okay this
doesn't look like so great for him but
but you're right no matter how long I
think I still couldn't find the best
move that's how bad I am
get out of my house get out of here
we're just going to trade everything
in a position that's completely winning
here for me I only have eight seconds
because I spent too long trying to play
good moves that's the first mistake
ah
oh you dirty dog very nice
all right fine fine fine fine fine fine
I feel like this whole like grunting why
you play was paying off for me
I think it was also the moves
the moves also mattered a bit
ah
you
whoa whoa
oh crap
Oh ma'am
you
all right come
watch out happening
a lot of pieces facing your king
don't care
if you should though
it's not enough it's not enough
by doing
yeah some ambush but it's not gonna
happen so I'm gonna make anymore
I'm not gonna make any more jokes I'm
not gonna make any more jokes here
my job you had a chance to blunder mate
there buddy
brap what am i doing no jokes anymore
here no there's no joke sorry
you know what you're learning
but the adoption process is complicated
yeah nah but I've done it very quickly
but you are first of all not such a bad
player at all more importantly yeah I'm
just having a beautiful beautiful bad
luck here and there
actually have only done it in bullets
yeah so I in bullet I think I can pretty
easily just that in bullet okay I ruined
that with the stupid joke but in bullet
I should do it pretty easily
[Music]
because I'm liking the song I'm you know
faster
better stronger
you
I want to strap your Bishop a little bit
but I don't know ya obsess over it and
shouldn't obsess over it as well
yeah I kind of went kind of went south
on me over there
you
on you still have a chance to blow this
one
I do
crap
but the chances chances have to be taken
you
now I'm in your head
no I just didn't expect you to you know
to be alert to my little moves I thought
you just gonna play as usual you played
paid attention to my moves
it's unfair
all up in your grill
I'm all up in your grill now
what grill the grill
that's what American American expression
it is an American expression yes you're
right
that's not the most technical okay
okay whoa
you
that's the beautiful move g4o yeah why
did I do that
literally don't know what I'm doing
right now
oh I can't take you oh I almost wanted
to so bad
you
yeah that's a vibe I always want to pray
look how many games by the way can you
believe like it's possible to win like
27 games and not have ten in a row like
yeah exactly that's why it's hard
shoutout to liquid egg product with the
$25 dono once again raising money for
charity
you
Oh
I don't even know
do you notice the count of the latest
game sir what do you know the count like
it what's the home game I think you'll
know more or only I think you're up to
four again you were at seven
and now you're down to four I think
okay now I really have to oh man that
was nasty
I'm so proud of you
thank you thank you thank you people
Thank You Chad oh crap I am so proud of
you for that though that was awesome
I mean I normally tell people never
forget about the Greeks gift and you
just taught taught me and my wife is
Greek and I still forget about it from
time to time you know though
yeah you did it on purpose to make me
feel better right say that again you did
it on purpose to make me feel better
right
well I mean
I don't want you to feel bad if that's
what you're asking yeah I don't do this
to make you feel bad
it's just that's just a perk
hmm
um let's see here some weird ways to
play these positions you know
that what I'm doing is any good
as flames you justifications in weird
ways and this is one of the worst it's
very specific how you played it I must
go active today I haven't quite
experienced this particular setup before
but
there certainly are some pros and cons
here more cons and pros dobut better
there is something to say for losing
tenth MP within the opening with white
something to say further that
you
this is so bad
I'm the worst of everything oh yeah yeah
but they're back to grunting yeah
alright here we go here we go here we go
here we go here we go here we go here we
go here we go
I'm switching it up so you sound like
you're Karen oh here we go here we go I
need to harness my inner Hikaru
oh man
really oh crap that's it it's so bad
[Music]
take that
literally or if you want to if you're
into it I'm really considered it yeah
okay okay I know I don't I don't expect
such bad moves I don't even write no but
it doesn't even matter my position is
still some bug Asst
oh man this is the thing is like I don't
think people realize how much pressure
is on right now when we're a year into
this show and every other super GM has
adopted me and you haven't that's gonna
feel so bad dude like like I'm just
gonna let the time right now for that to
sit it's a good one you're into the show
and you're the only one who couldn't
adopt me at least one of these time
controls you're gonna be you're gonna be
like teased by all the kids on the
playground well you know my weakness
this is so striking right there
everyone's gonna make fun I mean even
madness will throw his his hat in that
ring you know and and be making fun of
you yeah but that would be something you
have over him he can't claim to be
number one if he's never tried
yeah no that's it's one way for you to
Luhrmann
Oh Mia
you
go castle is still talking right there
yeah I know come on come on come on I
will wear
how bad this is don't you stress no but
I mean you had to go forward like a man
I I know
hey d5 I'm not a man
playing like a baby about time somebody
adopts you to be honest like a ninja man
child as they say we said I don't know
that I want you to be made fun of
mercilessly I mean I mean a purpose are
you trying to imply that you are losing
on purpose the difference what is sorry
what's the difference between you just
playing and you're losing on purpose
where is that board arena of it this is
getting so bad oh and I'm running out of
chances you're about to get your eighth
win okay I need to gather myself this is
my chance to deny a nice giri and make
him the laughingstock of super geum's
I'm pretty much up after this game right
here yeah so how many games left so yeah
well that's it I mean two games you
either adopt me or I stop you in these
next two games and how did Maxime
managed to adopt you he adopted me boy
in bulletin he failed in both five
minute three minutes
Wesley adopted me in both five minute
and one minute he failed in three minute
okay okay let's go here we go all right
gotta go back to old number one here
you
Wow you're playing really well this game
Shh
don't jinx it
no but it's uncool what you are doing
seriously this is really disturbing you
can do what you like but to say tell
someone that you are playing really well
during a game that's pretty much it's
just 3d no there's just really bad
manners and I just don't appreciate that
they're just completely uncool okay well
at least you're playing super well here
so don't blow it
no but I mean seriously yeah this is not
just not okay understand I understand we
are competitors here but still the games
are going to be finished and then we
want to go back to our normal
relationship I am about to lose
everything I here okay
my including my whatever last a little
bit of pride I have left
okay strong
let's try you alright ah
ah-ha-ha-ha
uh-huh
but you tricked me no like a pretty
relaxed seriously I didn't even Oh more
time versus boy you blew it cuz I comic
cuz I complimented you and then there's
below yeah I played very well until I
just completely lost concentration there
yeah that hurts so bad that hurts so bad
but I only had six seconds and I was
sure you were gonna flag me yeah but I
could have fallen to the perpetual yeah
it was very tempting to fill in the
perpetual yesterday I almost I almost
tricked you right I played Queen up for
him you had to find g3 so you get the
credit re This Is It this is it it's
either this game here you beat me
alright here we go
all comes down to this right here
another Sicilian you're dying on that
hill apparently
Carolee you are going to die on the
Sicilian Hill I respect that
I'm taking your advice I meant I meant
to d5 but whatever
ume-san you misunderstood my advice
Korea but it was different position wait
happening here that's not that's not yet
no no this is a piece
this is not a thing
all I have to do
is make something crazy happen that's it
I've been in bad spots before don't
worry my life
you
children when you have little material
when you are a piece down you should
trade all the pieces
that's what dr. Daniel rash wrench then
the ranch is gonna teach you the
straight way Rick wait how do you trade
trade 'old okay I hope this joke is not
too expensive yeah I hear I'm getting in
like anyhow no no that last game was my
chance you could still Amy King III oh
no crap I forget I thought you did for a
second oh you dirty no I don't think
there's a pawn take it I I do a payback
for the time my joke was not working
this one is working no I just forgot the
time dude give me a heart attack
next give me a heart attack I thought
you wondered stalemate yeah
this is your chance crap crap crap
father's day just got a lot more
expensive for me oh it's a beautiful
beautiful score we got 33 against three
it's not a lot of threes in there very
nice
well you did it thank you very much that
was very tough very tough the previous
game
that last game that last game was my
chance
all right
well I mean jokes it has been a lot of
fun and good for you you won't be made
fun of when you guys are all hanging out
in the super GM circle what you guys
look down on everybody else and you're
like hey I'm rubbing shoulders with
Magnus and a nice carry and it we
rallied and we've all adopted Danny here
you know now you won't be that one who's
left to the corner I suspect that you
are either either you are sort of not
doing your best
purpose or you are liking in some
confidence because you are definitely
playing sometimes much better than some
other times I appreciate that and I
think it is I mean if I'm just totally
honest we're talking chess player it's
just later these shows are tough to play
your best chess I mean mostly everything
I do is entertainment and I am generally
pretty distracted during these shows but
it is nice to hear I played a couple of
good games I appreciate that
no well for sure I mean there was some
remember when you gave Quinn a three
check that was a complete game simply
good game the one that you actually want
remember oh yeah yeah the Queen III yeah
yeah no I mean I will definitely be back
this is a favorite game of the event
right there yeah for sure for sure but
yeah it was good good to hear also that
some people were watching like Maxime
was watching it's good even I heard I
don't know if it's true but I heard that
even Hikaru was I was watching that's
Cara was watching us on his stream while
you were doing impersonations of him so
and it's just it's just an honor to make
it there I'm going to watch Hikaru
watching me on the stream I might not
but it's it's great and I'm really I
mean jokes aside as you as you could see
I mean a real fan of Hikaru's twitch
channel would sort of recognize that I
really know a lot about hiccups twitch
channel what you and he really do and I
mean it was like even the opening line I
played the employees very often so I am
really a big fan and it was all meant in
a very good faith and I'm really happy
that he's promoting the game of chess
and we're getting new audience there
people who are really like-minded and
like the game of chess but haven't yet
had a chance to encounter it and they
encounter it and they're gonna stay
chess friends and it's really great for
everyone so I think it's all meant meant
very well and my comparisons of whoever
I compared to mr. Bochy were also meant
well because I am of high opinion of mr.
Dozier and like was most of the people
giant Lisa that also apologized for my
for my poor reaction to my losses it had
nothing to do with the with the way
whatever your server works it all works
completely fine it's not me to expect to
expect to flag you when I have two
seconds and a bunch of pieces on the
board and yeah I think other than that
I'm sorry for everything else I've done
this is the best beach ever
welcome to the family tour welcome to
the family thank you already came by is
she left here some clothes I don't know
if it's for you it's just nice well I do
appreciate that
I'll make sure to think of you here a
Father's Day and I appreciate being
welcomed to the family say you know my
brother's name is Danny my name is Dean
I mean it feels good it feels like it
feels like where I belong and so one one
happy family yeah and jokes aside I'm
also a fan of mr. dodgy right I've just
you know we're all we're all fans of
every what everyone's doing for chess
and your bar everyone is barking up the
the twitch tree right now and it's
amazing to see the game growing so yeah
sure I mean and he's definitely I
as far as I know he doesn't have any
hidden agenda or motivation to but of
course inevitably I mean as some
sometimes I catch myself thinking the
same when someone is saying some
unpleasant things to me it doesn't
happen often of course but it sometimes
does then I realize that they do it in
order to protect the people they're fans
of whenever someone talks bad about me I
know they don't have an agenda they have
a good reason to do it not not a good
reason it's just that they are trying to
when for example they want to defend
magnums and then they attack you instead
and they just they yeah they mean well
but you are on the receiving end of it
so in that sense mr. Doad you might seem
unlikable by some but I think he never
meant means badly neither to do i or for
you but there are some bad people in the
world just yeah fortunately two are not
me and you are not are not bad people so
I think on this positive note we should
slowly conclude and I hope also you
gather some sound for the charity I
heard yeah we just got two more random
$50.00 donations from Colin and OTG also
shout out to binky we raised for it we
set out a goal for 250 bucks we raised
four hundred and twenty dollars it was
awesome it was awesome they're gonna be
helpful gonna be helpful for people who
need so that's that's great to hear and
I hope you'll have more fun in the
future I'm extremely relieved that I
managed to win there
complete my task you did I thought I was
gonna get you I thought I was gonna
escape and I didn't so alright man but
seriously thank you for doing this this
is a lot of fun and she had out to
everybody everyone who's been here I
don't even how many viewers we have
right now because I don't have any of
the live chatters up but thanks for
being here I'm it's awesome and alright
Anish you're the man yes thank you thank
you for good games I mean now she's
literally the man in the house you were
that you know you you were the pants you
are the daddy of me so thank okay I
don't know I don't know how it is in
your timezone but in my time zone it's
time for children to sleep already
alright well thanks for doing this and I
don't know when our next adopted Danny
will be everybody but stay tuned for
that
and I'm gonna work
my chess as a niche giri my daddy now
really pushing me I need to work on my
chest so Javed's everybody and we'll see
you we'll see you next time
[Music]
you